hello everybody and welcome to part two
of let's play lacasa all right we got
these things I'm pretty sure I must have
missed one somewhere I don't know though
all right good this one got that one got
that one got that one got that one maybe
oh I got a do them and then turn the
crank II dig yeah yeah that's it
oh damn it did they go off I don't know
I don't know nope I didn't do jack
doodlee alright um obviously I don't
know what I'm doing so I'm gonna go
somewhere else
whatever man whatever all right going
back to the dining hall I could imagine
this Hall was once filled with families
and children gathered around the tables
I thought this was supposed to be a
temple that's a family gathering all
right
Hey hi you I through you don't mess with
me bro yeah so I thought all right big
old box Oh behind there
all right what did I write down need a
more complex tool to clear the rock wall
how about a bomb it's pretty complex no
is this oh come on all right
um oh no I'm out of oil already got
Scotty stuff using that alright so I'm
guessing I gotta figure this stuff out
in the water works but let me just make
one last loop around who's in there
who's knocking Oh bring it on
scare me Oh got a chair URL URL so boned
ha ha all right piggy piggy
you made a squealing noise um let's see
back here maybe but put D or live the
leg on the fire okay all right there we
go just like that sounds all right that
didn't do it okay I got to go back to
the waterworks figure out what went
wrong
hello is anybody here nobody didn't
think so point all right it must be
something pulling those levers because
there's a reason for the timer there's
got to be maybe if I pull them in the
right order I don't know I don't know
I'm too stupid to figure this out I
would have got blood
wall nothing cave-in um dark dark oil
okay I tried this so if I do that and
run fast as I can go this one chunk and
then do this one chunk oh yeah I guess I
guess I just wasn't fast enough
okay what they do don't do anything
oh there we go Oh finally what do we get
oh here we go oh that did um something
okay there's another one here all right
oh these wheel these cranks are so much
better than in penumbra alright that did
I don't know
No huh what do i do what do i do I don't
know okay these reset themselves okay
maybe it's another time where I gotta
just hurry okay and then go go go oh
wait I see another one aha now I'm smart
okay that was three just like the three
outside and then a K Oh gimme yeah oh
yeah oh yeah hey oh my God my lantern
not again
Oh where's a lamp no lamp oh stove now
let me let that stove ah
all right he's gonna have to deal with
insanity for a little bit oh but I'm so
strong all right um how much a would
don't know why there's so many planks of
wood here is there anything there's
really no light for me to light that's
stupid
maybe if I leverage a piece of wood in
here nope nope nope nope nope nope nope
all right um
well I I'm in here I just don't know why
these are supporting something maybe I
need a plank of wood for something out
of one of these beers nope nope nope
nope nope and no monsters I'll bring it
on monsters bring it on
buddy you got okay here's the light I
went in there for a reason there had to
be a reason but I can't see anything
top shelf there's this trapdoor here is
there another switch on the walls I
can't see jack
alright seriously what's going on what's
going on yeah nothing nothing hold on
another all right I'm out of here I'm
taking a piece of wood with me
come here you what is that something had
to be had to be something but apparently
there is not something a whole lot of
nothing I can't even take this wood with
me
what the heck am i just stupid probably
probably all right let me check my
journal a more complex tool yeah what is
going on
oh you scope get down get down you stay
down all right man what what did it do
what did that do I do not know I don't
know no glowing don't know why all right
OOP well is to be expected I'm supposed
to get stuck on all the simplest puzzles
in the world there must have been
something with that trapdoor I must I
must be just missing something or I
didn't pull hard enough or I don't know
but there was another lever uh-huh I
don't know which my lantern hadn't gone
out of course I'm just stupid about my
Lantern juice huh nope maybe okay it's
clicking again maybe maybe that means
that I don't know
maybe it'll open the trapdoor if I do it
I don't know I don't know nope didn't do
anything all right there must be
something ah oh come on you gotta be
kidding me
I was just too wimpy ah oh you gotta be
kidding me oh I'm so stupid stupid
I'm also stupid cuz I'm crawling down a
ladder into the depths of Hell here but
stupid her for that cuz that was stupid
oh oh I have no lantern juice oh you
guys probably can't see a darn thing I
can't really see a thing either okay
moving on anyway
ah no something I needed o lantern oil
legend oil finally oh thank goodness
gravy gimme gimme gimme
Oh finally oh man that was nice of it it
filled up half my sting alright there
anything back there that I need get back
there okay no no I cannot
whoa hello whale mating call
alright Oh dark alright going back on
making progress cuz I'm a big fat idiot
all right monster pop out at the top huh
huh
anybody know yeah you knew it was good
for you get out of here
what duck what what's clicking clacking
huh why is it clicking I don't know
maybe he's still clicking from before
but that's kind of creepy
all right whatever whatever moving on
got my hammer oh yeah all right bring it
on what do we got what do we got
come on man Cisco I'm just thinking that
everything resets to its positions
all right probably break this thing uh
actually I have to cut here thank you
guys so much for watching and I will see
you guys in part 3 of let's play la caza
bye bye